des clôtures sont érigées Montréal
s'apprête à accueillir la COP15 soit de
sécurité si la circulation demeure
fluide aux abords du Palais des Congrès
les usagers du transport collectif
devront s'adapter la station de métro
Place d'Armes sera fermée du premier au
20 décembre ah ouais c'est un peu long
et ça me Pertuis pour partir au travail
ça va vraiment ça me perturbe 15
arrêtent d'autobus de la STM sont déjà
condamnés dans un périmètre élargi des
trajets seront donc déroutés le faut pas
oublier qu'au niveau du métro il y a la
ligne verte qui a fait une caféée qui
quelques centaines de mètres plus au
nord qui offre un trajet en parallèle
aussi pour des servir le centre-ville
vous voyez quand habituellement les gens
par ici ils sortent par ici ce
restaurateur dont le commerce se situe
dans le périmètre du Palais des Congrès
a appris aujourd'hui qu'il devra
condamner son entrée principale ben
c'est certain que certaines craintes les
policiers nous ont rencontrés hier nous
avons encore rencontré ce matin nous ont
expliqué comment cette idée de roulerait
c'est pas débuter on sait pas comment ça
va se dérouler le poids de toutes ces
mesures se fait même sentir sur les
travailleurs de la COP15 ce qui va
changer surtout c'est en tant que
technicien quand on entre au palais il y
a beaucoup de vérifications niveau
vérification au niveau du background
pour la GRC on va avoir des fois il y a
l'entrée il va avoir des listes de
matériel à pouvoir dire si on veut
entrer un simple outil dans le palais
des congrès c'est une éventualité malgré
les désagréments les hôteliers prévoient
faire des affaires en or avec la venue
anticipée de 10 à 15000 congressistes du
7 au 19 décembre pour nous c'est une
super opportunité c'est sûr que le mois
décembre habituellement c'est un mois
qui est plus calme au niveau de l'hôtel
donc ça nous apporte beaucoup de volume
en unité donc pour nous c'est reçu à
bras ouverts majeur parce qu'on attend
des retombées économiques imposante on
parle de plusieurs dizaines de millions
de dollars pendant près de deux semaines
la COP15 aura pour objectif d'établir un
cadre pour protéger la biodiversité ici
Jean-Philippe news Radio-Canada Montréal